[Music]
I hate Brian I am so glad you said that
I can't stand him oh thank you that's
all really worried seriously sucks right
[Music]
I actually don't love going to social
events which I never find a bit odd
because I come across as so extra versus
so my thing is that I quite like to keep
socks on Wow
yeah but it's just it's like kinky but
is also domesticate okay all right
what's your it's what kink um well no
judgment
Quan I'd like to get some straps you
[Music]
everything okay darling yeah well you
know if we're being honest with each
other totally honest I was saying that
waitress is so attractive I don't never
ever seen someone that's just so exactly
why I go for my time like what I find
attractive in a person you know just I'm
not saying I'm just you know objectively
[Music]
you
did you mean what you said earlier in
the restaurant about the waitress no to
be honest I completely forgot about her
and so you just said that ready yeah
you promise promise 100% okay
[Music]
okay yeah oh yeah you know what it what
are you thinking about well I'm just
thinking you know what it doesn't matter
really yeah
yes honestly darling it doesn't matter
okay
you
[Music]
if you liked this film download our app
where you can view all our videos read
articles from the Book of Life and chats
with other students of the School of
Life